à vocation poule quand le recrutement
n'est plus ce qu'il était et le malaise
s'installe
ayant à grève demain dans les écoles et
les collèges grève dans l'éducation
nationale dans les années 80 grève
aujourd'hui avec les mêmes
revendications
les professeurs des écoles des collèges
et des lycées se disent mal considérés
c'était déjà le cas en 1987
le fait d'être prof d'être enseignant
c'est plus du tout une marque de
considération sociale est bon quand on
est con et profs on se fait traiter de
fainéant enfin pas mal de nous y passe
vous êtes tout le temps grève vous
foutez rien vos élèves sont nuls ont
maintenant à croire que tu vraiment fou
rien c'est vrai que c'est assez d
considérons manque de considération
aussi de la part de l'état qui se
traduit par des salaires insuffisants
selon les professeurs exemple en 1981
notre image comme elle est à l'image de
notre salaire c'est à dire c'est
réellement dévalorisé beaucoup de
parents sont très étonnés lorsque l'on
est en parlant
mais fallait ou encore en 1989
je trouve qu'on est déjà bien méritant
d'être professeur et travailler avec la
paix qu'on a dans des conditions dans
lesquelles on travaille des mauvaises
conditions de travail
c'est aussi une des revendications
actuelles mais qui existait déjà en 1981
notre tâche consiste à préparer dès
demain avec les enfants d'aujourd'hui on
met avec souvent des moyens de vieilles
télés nom est certain la longueville des
locaux qui datent encore de jules ferry
il ceci pose problème pour faire une
écologie de l'an 2000 des locaux
vétustes mais aussi des classes
surchargées scandaleuse
c'est un malaise profond je crois dans
les établissements du second degré
d'autant plus que nous accueillons
encore plus d'élèves cette année il y
aura presque plus de 1000 élèves dans
les établissements du rhône et que nous
avons en poste ferait en tout et pour
tout deux postes pour les collèges et 19
postes pour les lycées ce qui est quand
même très insuffisant pour rénover la
pédagogie pour entreprendre quelque
chose de différent de façon à construire
l'école de la réussite conditions de
travail salaires reconnaissance bien
être au travail
d'après le dernier baromètre du syndicat
unsa seulement 28,2 pour cent des
enseignants disent ressentir de la
reconnaissance et du respect dans leur
pratique professionnelle
ils étaient 36 % l'année dernière
[Musique]